Okay.
Today I want to talk about the Paris commune.
This is how I end the previous course,
but it's the most appropriate place to start this one because the Paris commune
hung over Europe,
uh,
for,
the next 20 or 30 years.
Uh,
and in my view,
uh,
the 20,
the Paris commune in the massacre that,
uh,
that followed the Paris commune massacre of thousands and thousands of people
anticipated the 20th century when you became guilty for who you just being who
you were a party to the moon.
It's a coop,
Bob,
uh,
Paris in Paris,
everybody was guilty.
A shout it out.
One of the prosecutors as they shot men and women down.
Uh,
it would be,
and I'll conclude with this,
the the largest massacre,
uh,
that,
would take place until the massacre of Armenians by a Turks in the latter years
of the 19th century and in,
uh,
in World War One as well,
in 1915.
Um,
and it,
it,
it sadly anticipates,
uh,
the,
the horror shows of the 20th century to the moon that they could probably,
you were guilty because you were left in Paris because you were too poor to get
out.
So what was,
uh,
the Paris commune?
Uh,
some of you already know this,
but let me talk about that and then give you my view on it.
Uh,
the Paris commune has to be placed in the context of two things going on.
One is that during the second empire,
which was that regime of Napoleon,
the third that lasted from 1850 to two till he was really rounded up by the
Prussians in,
uh,
1870,
there was in the late 1960 [inaudible] late 1860s,
a revival of Republican and Socialist Organization and of Ann Arkis
Disorganization,
uh,
if you will,
in June,
uh,
in 1868,
the emperor legalizes public meetings,
which had been illegal,
uh,
and in,
in Paris and in very many places,
particularly on the edge of Paris and the margins of urban life,
you had meetings in large warehouses and in big cafes where people discuss
politics and imagined reforms that they wanted in the empire,
or many of them wanted a republic or some sort of democratic,
a socialist,
a republic.
So there's a political mobilization in the late 1860s,
and in the beginning of 1870,
uh,
there is a wave of strikes.
Strikes had been illegal in France until 1864 unions would be illegal in France
until 1881.
Uh,
but so you had a wave of strikes.
So that's really the first context and the mobilization of many ordinary people,
uh,
living in Paris.
The second context is the Franco Prussian war,
which you can read about in chips,
our wines book.
But basically what happens is that Louis Napoleon and Napoleon the third get
suckered into a war without any allies at all because of various,
uh,
dumb things that he'd done against the very clever,
extremely aggressive Otto von Bismarck.
Uh,
the Prussian,
a chancellor,
uh,
it involves one of those obscure things that one had to learn in,
in,
uh,
western Civ,
the way it was taught a long time ago.
Uh,
it,
uh,
well I suppose it's worth remembering any and involve the candidacy,
of,
of a royal family member,
rather obscure one for the throne of France,
which would have left France surrounded by the royal family of Prussia.
Holin Zolar [inaudible] a name that in this course you need,
not a retain and lettuce and some extraordinary complicated crossword puzzle.
But,
uh,
no,
Napoleon,
uh,
protests vigorously,
and then trying to add insult to injury.
Uh,
his ambassador literally chases the German emperor around his garden,
uh,
and is,
a fairly abusive in a verbal way.
And Bismark seizes on this to stoke up,
uh,
anger against France and then reveals,
to the European world are those people who cared,
uh,
that,
Napoleon the third had earlier tried to make a deal,
which,
uh,
in exchange for supporting Prussia against Austria,
he would receive Belgium and Luxembourg,
which of course,
uh,
the British could never tolerate.
And so what happens is that he goes to war in the summer of 1870,
uh,
without any allies against Prussia and itself,
German,
uh,
allies,
and he thinks he's going to win.
But as my team was in Michigan Stadium last Saturday with me and me present sad,
very sad person you're looking at,
uh,
he was blown out.
Uh,
and uh,
on September 4th,
1870,
uh,
there is yet another insurrection in Paris,
a crowd storms down to the town hall.
They seize power.
They proclaim a republic,
they named streets different names,
and they want to prolong the resistance against the Prussian army,
which has a Subaru trail.
And cleverly organized military victories is sweeping,
uh,
aside French,
a resistance in the Polian.
The third who's very sick,
he would die a couple of years later,
probably have stomach cancer,
is,
uh,
is captured,
Eh,
uh,
in the battle of Saddam s e d a,
n,
which is a textile town in,
uh,
near the Belgium border in the north of France.
And he goes off to,
uh,
is sent packing off to Britain.
Now,
uh,
what happens then is that,
there are those who want to keep fighting.
Uh,
it's quite clear that,
uh,
one of the demands of Prussia,
and as of late January,
a unified Germany,
uh,
Germany,
the German empire was proclaimed in the hall of mirrors and the Chateau
Versailles,
uh,
by coincidence,
but one of the demands is that there'll be a huge indemnity,
which the French will have to pay.
And that El Sauce and law hen that eastern those eastern provinces,
largely German speaking,
I remind you,
uh,
would be amputated.
And after the Paris region,
uh,
and we'd be a next by Germany and af after the Paris region,
Alsace and Lauryn,
uh,
were,
the two most industrialized and prosperous parts of France.
And so in Paris,
uh,
people,
find themselves a surrounded,
uh,
here we go.
The screen is that the right screen?
I never know who the hell knows
how that works.
They find themself,
uh,
surrounded,
and,
uh,
Paris is,
it has nothing like it's one third the size of London at the same time or at any
other time,
but it has a huge conference.
Uh,
there was a wall around Paris and there are exterior forts,
but you've got an enormous number of people besieged by Prussian,
uh,
and other,
German,
uh,
forces holding on.
At one point,
a French politician whom you'll meet in the textbook,
at least called Gumby ta,
who died very young,
uh,
flies away in a balloon,
flies down toward tool,
uh,
on the lower valley to try to re re rise up.
Uh,
uh,
raise up resistance there,
but things get quickly very grim indeed.
Uh,
uh,
in October of friends general of capitulates,
rather scandalously in the town of mess,
uh,
in the east,
which would become a German town.
In fact,
you've go to the mets,
maybe if some of your vendor myths,
uh,
you'll see this huge sort of [inaudible] railroad station that was clearly built
in,
in the second or of,
of,
uh,
of the Kaisers and,
and of,
uh,
of Bismarck.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
Paris,
is,
uh,
is surrounded in this sort of glory that was supposed to be the empire has
collapsed on the head of,
um,
of France.
And to be sure there were lots of crowds in Paris,
there were the inevitable crowds who shouted for,
uh,
for war,
which was sort of odd because Paris was increasingly a left wing city because
the vast majority of the population of Paris were ordinary people,
uh,
were,
workers more about that.
Uh,
uh,
another time when,
when I talk about Paris,
uh,
but the siege,
goes,
uh,
this siege goes on and on.
I'm in Paris.
Cha changes appearances,
military dress or parts of uniform become,
uh,
become seen.
Uh,
uh,
just about everywhere.
Uh,
the Po,
the problem is feeding all of these people.
Uh,
how are you going to,
uh,
how are you?
How are you going to feed him?
Uh,
you've got,
uh,
you know,
we've got all sorts of,
of,
of of animals.
You've got horses which you need for the army,
but also,
which they start slaughtering.
You've got cattle,
but you have enough food to last for maybe a month.
There's always a lot to drink because of the cost of that is the,
uh,
of the wine cellars that,
that people had.
But things get worse and worse.
The last regular mail delivery was on September 19th,
and thereafter they use balloons.
Uh,
the balloon was invented in the owl dash,
uh,
by Gulf ea,
in,
in the late 18th century.
And the balloon becomes a sort of symbol of,
of perhaps liberty.
Uh,
the people in Paris are awaiting,
uh,
some sort of military help from other provinces,
but it's simply goes on and on.
Um,
and during the siege,
there were 65 balloon flights carrying two and a half million letters,
wing,
a grand total of 10,000,
uh,
kilograms.
So roughly about 20,000 pond,
uh,
pounds.
One astronomer actually left Paris to go oss and to,
uh,
observe,
Eh,
an eclipse.
Uh,
they begin using pigeons in order to fly messages out.
And then the Germans who were crisp portrayed,
uh,
as committing atrocities,
and they didn't care.
They'd committed a few,
they'd shut some people up in the,
in the north east,
but nothing that would,
it would,
it like would occur in 1914.
Uh,
and of course,
nothing at all.
Like what would occur in very different circumstances.
1939,
1940,
the Germans bring in the,
the these falcons,
uh,
and,
and they go out and they munched the pigeons.
And so this was another reason for them to dislike the,
uh,
the Germans as these poor little pigeons who became the sort of sacred day,
a bird,
I guess,
a pigeon's,
a bird.
Uh,
and you know,
pigeons have been people,
people including me,
eat pigeons.
I mean if PJ no is actually a quite good,
but anyway,
um,
uh,
it,
it seemed like an awful thing to do when they're bringing these falcons and the
hawks who were imported to intercept these people.
Now the Paris population included national guardsman come from the outside,
uh,
to take refuge in side.
So it's rather like a medieval siege.
Uh,
from that point of view,
you've got people from the,
the outskirts coming in,
uh,
for food and safety,
but the population is slightly over 2 million people and that's allowed a lot of
miles to feed.
You've got 1500 Americans,
several whom leave accounts of the whole thing,
40,000 Belgians,
30,000 Swiss and 5,000 English.
Um,
so you're starting out with about 25.
Please don't write these down.
24,000 cattle,
150,000 sheep,
6,000 hogs.
Uh,
and that is not enough to eat.
And people become quite obsessed with what they're going to eat.
And you're looking at somebody who basically does not like dogs at all,
but who loves cats?
I and canine butchers replaced horse butchers are the horses had mostly been
eaten up or had been camp commandeered,
as I said before,
uh,
by the army.
You can still in France today,
uh,
find,
not canine butchers.
You can find a horse butchers and it's always a red,
uh,
front with a goal to head of a horse appropriately enough.
But people began to eat,
uh,
first,
the first,
but the eight,
the animals in the zoo.
Uh,
and uh,
what's his name?
A castor and pollux who have many appreciate children.
Generations had gone to visit the zoo of find themselves eaten,
uh,
and they can't eat the tigers cause they're afraid to open the cages.
And unfortunately the tiger is simply,
you know,
Croak,
uh,
because they're not going to waste food on them from their point of view,
but they began eating dogs and cats.
And so you had this rather odd situation where instead of dogs,
uh,
guarding,
their master's or mistresses,
you had the masters and mistresses guarding the dogs,
uh,
against people who would take the dogs and unfortunately kill them and eat them.
Uh,
and they eat cats as well.
and of course,
rats and,
and,
uh,
Paris had and still has millions of rats.
Uh,
even in the,
uh,
if you could come home about two or two 30 in the morning neuro,
our apartment,
you can still see rather large,
ah,
rats dashing across the,
uh,
across the street.
Some of them who looks so bloated,
they looked like some da or wild boar.
Uh,
which you can see occasionally in,
in parts of,
uh,
of rural France.
Uh,
there were tales,
inevitable tales of,
of,
uh,
w with French food is here.
You know,
the presentation counts for,
uh,
for something very much.
You know,
when food arrives,
you're likely to say,
see,
be on plays on T.
I mean,
it has all sorts of meanings to it as well,
presented theirs,
but it's how it looks,
but how it served and,
and of course,
how,
how it tastes,
where,
uh,
you would have,
unfortunately just pains me when I think of my poor little kitty,
uh,
you know,
a cat,
uh,
with Mike,
with mice artfully,
uh,
placed around the cat carcass.
One has to call it that.
What do you have carcass of cat,
uh,
and,
people simply got by as best they could.
And so they have this,
uh,
um,
in Bismarck had predicted that the seeds would end if previsions went several
weeks without their cafe au Lait,
the whole thing would be over.
But they create a central commission of hygiene and sobriety,
which tell people,
you know,
encourage people to eat healthfully,
and they don't just,
you know,
get wasted all the time.
Uh,
uh,
which is what I would have done,
I'll tell you that.
But no,
I take that back.
I do not film that.
Uh,
um,
they,
uh,
here's the proposed menu that we're,
don't have to know French to know this,
but here's the menu that they're,
this is early in the siege.
Uh,
the words for French's Shavasana and here's a menu for business people.
These people must have been freaky,
are fairly wealthy to,
to be able to eat like this.
But here's what you don't even have to know French to,
to get this.
It starts with a [inaudible] Chavon Chevelle.
We,
oh shoot.
Coolattas Chavela mud coated.
The Chavela boy has a leadership.
Hoti booth is Chavela Sally Fla.
Uh,
it couldn't do much with,
with horse ice cream.
So it sort of trailed by the end.
And as somebody once wrote many a suburb,
a suburb,
many,
a superb champion of La Shawn.
That is the race track,
uh,
met their end on the table of some well heeled person from the western fancy
districts of Paris.
But it ceased being funny.
I,
and it was nothing like the siege of,
of a,
of Leningrad were something like a million people died in World War II of
starvation.
But there were all sorts of little caskets being dragged along to what past then
for mortuaries old people and young people,
the youngest died in droves.
Uh,
and of course,
sheer drunkenness,
uh,
becomes an enormous problem.
And so did venereal disease because of the Paris at any one time,
depending on,
you know,
who's counting,
but,
but the number of prostitutes was at least 10,000 and probably about 25,000.
Uh,
and Sylvan year old disease becomes rampant.
and,
uh,
they're also a very strange cases of,
of,
of mental illness that were predictable.
There are people who,
uh,
are brought into a mental institutions who literally think that there Joan of
arc,
uh,
you know,
who was,
uh,
burned,
you know,
old kind of a dose.
I shouldn't say that,
but,
uh,
in a law,
in,
in the 15th century or there people that believe that their God or that their
Saint Louis and can somehow save a France.
So by a hunger sets in and it becomes extremely,
um,
uh,
extremely sad and tragic and attempts to break out,
simply don't work.
Um,
but it had his light moments and I can never resist those.
Uh,
they do a contest.
and those who would like to enter a contest saying,
how can we break out of this awful mess?
Oh,
whatever can we do?
And just three of the suggestions that came in that I would have awarded them
some sort of prize and,
uh,
we're,
we're the following or maybe just a two of them.
One,
somebody says that you did all these prostitutes,
uh,
are a valuable resource for Paris.
I mean,
Berlin had its own,
you know,
sad,
uh,
legions of prostitutes as well,
and that they must be equipped with what they called Prosec,
a prosec as impression,
but Prusick needles that would have a poison.
Uh,
and then the prostitutes would go out to encounter,
uh,
in some sort of cash exchange,
Prussian soldiers and at some key moment in the exchange would stab them in the
neck very gently with this pin.
That would be the end of their eating.
Uh,
uh,
sauerkraut.
Uh,
and then Paris would,
uh,
would,
free,
uh,
free itself.
Uh,
somebody else suggested that because of,
of,
uh,
influence of Wagner and because of the traditional kind of Oompah music that the
presion is always associated with,
with the,
uh,
Germans that you would track,
take the orchestras of Paris and teach them how to play Oompah music.
Uh,
this is what they called it.
I'm not the Prussians of course.
Uh,
and that the one day they simply would open up that one of the gates of Paris
heavily defended and would march out playing this music.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
behind them would become this huge Trojan horse,
which with which they would call the musical myths years,
uh,
or the musical machine gun,
which would then open up and start blasting away.
Uh,
uh,
the,
you know,
the poor Prussians were always,
always assumed to be by the,
by the sneaky thought Asian regions to bees.
Very dumb.
But of course,
they weren't.
And the other,
or somebody wrote in and said,
well,
let's just take this huge tarp,
put it on the plus icon called,
uh,
put Bacon and other things and use pigeon power and all the pigeons would come
to the place.
And then you and Gulf,
the pigeons,
and you have this powerful balloon that can carry all of these people in some
sort of,
some sort of airborne stagecoach or Denise Jones out of Paris.
Uh,
but the,
the thing collapse,
I mean,
it,
it becomes a less and less funny and not at all.
And it's the very beginning,
there was a train that went around the wall of Paris,
more about the walls of Paris and other time that's fun to talk about in
prisons.
We take picnic lunches and they'd get on the train and then they hear these
large explosions and realize that they could get killed by these large
explosions.
And so as things are going downhill,
uh,
the,
many people in Paris said,
look,
we must keep fighting,
but we must imagine a different world where we have a,
we were being betrayed by the provinces that are not helping us.
And we need to have,
uh,
we,
we need to have help from the provinces.
Uh,
and in January somebody puts up a sign,
a big red sign,
red being the color of the left.
Red was illegal.
The color red,
red was illegal between 1849 and 1851,
uh,
because it was believed to excite one group of people against another,
which is an exact quote from the French law I,
and it's a big read,
a poster that says,
make way for the Commun that the people of Paris would have the right to defend
themselves and to create a better world in the future.
Now let me scramble for my,
uh,
okay.
Well this will be scramble front implement here.
Uh,
this is ironically from 19,
I mean from 1869.
Uh,
and this is a euro conservative response to the mobilization of French workers.
And this says,
you know,
the working class population won't at all listen to bad advice.
And notice here,
this guy,
this is your basic Parisian Urchin who in 18 30th in a delicate,
famous Eloqua painting called liberty leaving and the people is sort of the
hero.
But here he started the bad guy,
sort of a governess,
gone,
totally wrong.
Uh,
and and hear his temptation.
And here's this working class,
a family that will surely resist all of this.
And this is God.
I love this.
You know,
when picked,
when you first see the first picture you can actually see of Paris,
is that what they call a dead guy with Tepe from 18?
Uh,
I mean from,
from uh,
18,
uh,
37,
the full blow a do tank.
And you can actually,
instead of imagining what things look like,
you can see them and hear it.
This is from the steps of [inaudible] way before the godawful separate core was
built.
The basilica more about that some other time when I'm in a real frenzy of,
of,
of contempt for,
uh,
the destruction of the Parisian skyline.
But anyway,
uh,
this looking down for,
you know,
from,
from Oman and here you've got the image of the female image of liberty,
Maryanne,
and she comes in as the provisional government that is going to capitulate.
France is going to,
uh,
you know,
give up,
uh,
and,
but not that it's going to make a damn bit of difference.
And then I,
I'd off Tia,
who,
somebody wants to call it a miserable gnome,
uh,
t h,
I e r s adults,
a Tiana is there and he's cutting off the right arm of France,
uh,
which is Alsace.
And Lauren was stressful,
cool.
To Marvin and the WHO and all these important things.
And here,
uh,
this is Marianne being martyred by the French provisional government.
And in the back is the,
is the,
is it the dawning of their social republic of the left that is these ordinary
people who have fought so long and so hard.
Um,
so Paris,
capitulates France,
not Paris,
but France could prepare the provisional government per se.
Uh,
uh,
capitulates,
in the end of,
of,
uh,
January,
of,
uh,
your 1871,
and the,
the oppression troops,
cavalry marched down a horse just don't march they trot,
but they trot down the shots of these a and then the concierge from,
from that area go and,
and symbolically and for real intent also clean up the stones afterward and
there's a huge indemnity that has to be paid off.
And France,
we'll lose Alsace.
Loran so France has this provisional government,
I mean,
you can read about this stuff,
it's not that interesting,
uh,
in was passionately interesting.
But in February of 1871,
their elections and the provinces,
the conservative western provinces like Brittany return is extremely monarchists
dominated national assembly that is going to determine the future of France.
And the landlords come back to Paris because they had somewhere to go during the
siege and they say,
you pay up,
you pay up money with interest.
And the provisional government says,
yes,
you pay up money with interest and people had no money.
Uh,
uh,
and there's just incredible anger and tear who in 1848 had advised another
regime that fell to revolution that is of the July monarchy,
uh,
the plotting Louie Felipe to withdraw the troops from Paris.
Uh,
Eh,
you know,
in the account of,
of,
uh,
if there's any trouble in Paris.
He already had this in mind.
Uh,
on March 18th,
1871,
he sends troops to Moma,
the hill of [inaudible],
the highest point in Paris,
which had only been a next in 1860 on January 1st Mamata,
which still had this somewhat rural atmosphere.
There's still a wine producer.
It's all,
you know,
the vineyard is about as big as this room.
It's just so they can sell the label,
you know,
of,
uh,
wine.
Uh,
from there because the national guard of Paris that had defended parasol
heroically,
they still have got these guns.
And so,
um,
they have these guns and so they send the guns or they send the troops to get
the guns.
Early in the morning.
The women who are at the market see the troops coming,
they call the men folk.
The men folk.
Take two generals of the provisional government,
they put them up against the wall and they shoot them and Tiara says,
now we're going to get these bastards.
And he pulls all the troops out,
headquartered appropriate and FM.
They'll sigh.
And Paris is surrounded again by,
uh,
this case,
somebody else's government that is the provisional government.
So the commune begins on the 18th of March,
1871.
And it lasts until the end of May,
1871,
Lennon,
one's called the festival of the oppressed.
And Lennon was wrong about many things.
He's right about a few things,
but wrong about many,
but he got that one right.
And so for the first time,
ordinary Parisian is found themselves masters of their own lives.
So wealthy people mostly got out again.
And the commune holds on,
uh,
the commune.
The numbers of the Commun were swollen by political refugees.
This is a woman called Elizabeth Dimitria,
F who was a Russian militant,
who was one of the leaders of the commune.
And as in the French revolution that has 1789 and following,
and as in 18,
48 clubs of women began to form demanding rights and the commune,
uh,
despite the fact that there's lots of,
you could hear in the distance,
the guns sometimes getting closer and closer and attempts to break out,
fail miserably.
They pass all sorts of impressive social legislation.
They create nursery school nurseries for working women.
Uh,
they give contracts to make national guard uniforms to women's unions.
they,
uh,
plan what will be a lay secularized education system.
Uh,
they banned night baking,
uh,
because it was,
not good for the health of people working in,
uh,
in bakeries in the middle of the night.
And here's a women's,
a women's club making demands.
Nobody is yet,
except these women thinking of female suffered.
So it's kind of a,
it's kind of an important moment in the history of women.
And also it explains the viciousness of the,
of the attempt of,
of the,
uh,
of the massacre really of ordinary working class women when the whole thing
falls apart because the women were conceived of as being uppity as putting forth
claims that they shouldn't be making,
uh,
by,
conservatives and a couple of the Columbia.
Now one is a woman that you will read about later called Louise Louise and
Michelle,
uh,
who spends half of her time in,
in,
uh,
in exile in London,
who is an anarchist basically,
uh,
was very important along with Elizabeth Dimitria.
And so you're surrounded,
uh,
and the people,
they don't agree on everything.
You've got a Jacoba,
you know,
Jacobins who are the sort of centralized,
uh,
radical Republicans are socialists from the French revolution.
You've got anarchist who wanted not to take over the state,
but to destroy it.
I'm going to talk about anarchist another time because I'm writing a book about
one of them.
Uh,
uh,
and,
you've got to moderate Republicans who simply wanted Paris to have more
liberties.
Visa vi this strongly centralized state.
More about that.
Next time you've got moderate socialists,
you've got this whole kind of different people.
Uh,
and they're meeting around tables and talking and arguing and debating and
yelling and hugging long into the night.
Uh,
as the guns draw nearer.
There were communes in other cities too,
with a variety of,
of,
of demands and Limos and Luke Cruzo,
uh,
in Santa Tn and not been in Leone.
And in my essay,
uh,
and even an attempt to in Bole Dole and Paris keeps waiting for these armies to,
of citizens to come,
uh,
and sit to a yen,
female citizens also to come and rescue them.
But in the meantime,
you've got people from the northern and northeastern quarters of Paris,
the poor living on the edge of Paris who come down into the fancy quarters for
the very first time or not working in someone's made.
And they summit and the painter,
Gustave Courbet,
Gustava Cool Bay,
the naturalist painter from near Bezos,
Saul,
thus burial at or no,
uh,
he says,
why don't we as a sim,
we'll get rid of this horrible statue of Napoleon that standing on the Vendome
column.
And the Plus Vendome,
the platform dorm was and neuropathy royale,
very fancy.
It's known to Americans who have visited there,
many but others because that's the,
the Ritz hotel where,
uh,
what's her name of Princess Diana left,
you know,
10 years ago now and never made it unfortunately for her out of the polling
data.
Ma I the tunnel,
he says,
let's tear the whole damn thing down.
And so this is,
uh,
this is,
an entry pass to see this,
to see this thing brought down as a symbol of,
of centralized oppression.
And this is the whoops cheese.
This is the result.
This is the crashing.
And so people would come down,
they'd have their pictures taken with a picture as if it was the part of the
true cross of the crashed VOD dome column.
Because for once they had one for once,
they had one.
And so they have to defend Paris.
And so you've got all these cannons that you just saw before and you've got,
you know,
they,
they still have their uniforms and they build these huge barricades.
The first barricades,
by the way,
we're built in Paris in the late 16th century.
So there's a long tradition and you could build barricades across smaller
streets but not across big boulevards.
And that was part of the rebuilding of Paris and the 1850s and sixties more
about that in a minute and much more about it that later cause it's fascinating.
These I think is fascinating.
And here you go right down by the sin.
You know,
there's a,
there's some Monet and money pains both had that are further back from further
back looking over here.
You've got your basic barricade and these things are torn up.
You know,
these are were trees.
It came out of [inaudible] and as a 1968 and here's your sort of kiosk of
modernity.
You know,
somebody selling a newspaper's on these boulevards or near these boulevards and
here are some of these people and most of them would be dead within a month of,
of this,
uh,
of this photo.
And there you are looking at them trying to,
uh,
protect,
trying to protect their city.
Now,
now who,
first of all,
what,
who were the Columbia now who are,
who are the people that was the left?
Well,
you know,
when,
when revolutions are Victoria,
everybody rushes forward and says it.
They laugh.
You know,
I was there and they give their name and their address and,
and you know,
why don't you reward me or at least a beat,
pay attention to the fact that I,
that I was there in Paris,
you've got the victory column of the Revolution of 1830 where the bus teed,
wants dead as a student has got the names of all the people that were killed,
uh,
in three days of July,
1830.
But in something like this,
you,
you have a body count of it,
more than 15,000 people.
So we know who the academy now were.
There were ordinary people.
There were the ordinary workers,
uh,
men and women who simply couldn't get out.
They weren't all socialists,
as I said,
some more anarchist,
some are moderate Republicans,
but they were,
who were left.
Um,
they were,
uh,
their very presence there.
I'd be,
that's where they lived.
But they're defensive.
Paris reflects tensions between urban France and conservative rural France.
Uh,
the armies that they were opposing,
the French armies,
uh,
were,
largely staffed by peasants from conservative areas or from national guards
broadened from towns like vine or ava or all sorts of places that are brought
in.
Uh,
and so the Commun,
you know,
it's,
it's somewhat semi proletarian.
They're mostly working people.
They're particularly people from the poorer quarters of the north and the
northeast.
More about that later.
Uh,
they are who w,
you know,
the people that were left,
they are artisans,
craftsmen,
a day laborers,
domestic servants.
Uh,
they are the people who were left.
And what they were trying to do is imagine a world,
uh,
you know,
a new world in which would be less centralized,
but for the socialists,
they wanted more centralization.
So it was a very complex,
complex,
uh,
period.
Uh,
indeed,
but it reflects,
uh,
the artist and we'll base that was still part of,
part of the,
of,
uh,
of the,
of the French economy for sure.
With it,
with the emphasis on skilled production of,
of,
uh,
of handbags and of gloves and a finely crafted tables.
Uh,
the cabinet makers were always terribly important in the French revolution and
they still are,
and they're still all the stores,
but most of the stores on one particular street in Paris near the busty are
still a furniture store stores.
Um,
and the kind of myth of the commune was of course that,
uh,
from the conservative point of view is that these were the furious of hell.
The men and the women who rose up to slay their social betters.
Well,
of course that's not the case.
That's a sort of myth for the French Revolution as well.
And then you had your basic,
a republican interpretation is that they were defending the republic against
this sort of a monarchy to be restored.
And that certainly is part of that,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
but it also had its socialists component and,
and,
and marks for Marxists was terribly important.
And for lending it was as well.
It seemed to be,
uh,
Armageddon for the ruling classes.
But it seemed to be here was this proletariat,
even though Mark's got that all wrong,
because these are not industrial workers for the most part,
but these are the workers that one day break off their change chains.
And so you can see how this would have an impact on,
uh,
on,
every country on the United States.
Uh,
those who taken American history.
I mean,
this sort of view that the,
that the,
that immigrants were increasingly bringing a socialism and anarchism to the
United States.
Uh,
the communism important in the big Hay market affair,
the collective memory of the Commun,
the Haymarket affair in Chicago,
and that people hung there in,
in,
when was it,
1886.
Um,
but the most important,
uh,
really the most,
the most important,
uh,
result of it was the massacre,
I think itself,
because when finally the troops,
uh,
of the provisional government come pouring through the western gate,
a gate that essentially been left open,
uh,
in a place called Posse,
where there's some very nice art nouveau buildings by the way,
but which was very collaborationist also in World War II.
They're not everybody.
Uh,
what they do the troops do is they use the boulevards that had been built by
Napoleon,
the third as a way of getting to those working class neighborhoods that had
always risen up and Napoleon the third and his,
a prefect of the sin and a name you don't have to remember now,
but sometime of be nice to remember called Oh,
Smollen a name.
So important,
uh,
that it became a verb to ost man.
Something was to bulldoze it.
A man,
this to by my late friend Richard Cobb is the l station,
a Tila.
He had plowed through working class neighborhoods and built the boulevards that
w of the modern Paris that one celebrates and where one's celebrates.
He did it to bring more light.
He did it to bring more air.
He did it to free the flow for capital money.
That's the department stores are on the boulevards.
I'll do this again,
not this whole lecture,
but that part again.
And he did it because you can't build barricades across boulevards wide ones.
1944 August,
we jump ahead the boulevard.
The barricades are across the same streets where they were in many cases in 1792
and in 1789 and the problem 1968 it was very hard to build a barricade across
the boulevard San Michelle,
which was built by Rosemont at this time.
So the troops come pouring in.
This is down the route of [inaudible],
which was completed in the 1850s and sixties.
And the damage is staggering.
This is the Church of the Madeleine,
which is still there.
This is the rule royale.
These treats do not matter.
It's just the visual images with what is really going on that counts the hotel
de Ville,
which was destroyed.
Interestingly enough,
10 years ago,
somebody found photos taken by this Parisian of the siege and the commune in the
back of the Hotel Ville.
They were found 10 years ago.
They had survived.
I just saw an exposition of them at the end of the tech guy used to it because
I've used the puppy in,
in January of,
of,
of photos that had never been seen before.
But anyway,
this is,
uh,
this is the,
the,
the hotel,
the visa,
which is down by notes to dom though it's not an CTA,
don't worry about these places.
And then they put the women on trial.
There had been a rumor that female incendiaries in French,
they,
Petro Lewis had been setting fire to fancy houses and had been burning down the
Bank of France.
And so the rumor was part of the fear of quote unquote uppity women putting
forth demands and they squished them like grapes and they hauled them off and
shot them going.
Cool.
One of the writers,
they're going core,
the one that when it hadn't died yet was no friend of ordinary people.
But there's an amazing scene in his memoirs when he's down by the hotel,
the,
the sees these women chained together being walked around and he says,
well,
what,
where are they going instead of the guy next to him says,
well,
they're going to shoot him.
So what do you mean going to shoot him?
You didn't shoot women do they with a debt?
And he describes it.
It's terrifying.
I used to read it.
I could never get through it.
It's terrifying.
And then he hears the Kuda glasses,
the shots one after another and then he sees a priest staggering out,
overwhelmed by it all and then he moves on to something else.
The execution.
This is my ne who is horrified by the whole thing.
Uh,
my name wasn't there.
Kobe also did,
uh,
an ex execution scene.
And in the end what there was,
was this a thought,
he tuned them on that they could bop Paris.
Everybody was guilty,
little coffin.
People were smaller.
Then you can still see in the Pantanal this our secular monument to to some very
wonderful people like a immune soda.
But also you don't just Napoleonic generals one after another.
You can still see bullet holes there from the commune,
not just from World War Two,
from where were people were executed.
And they,
lots of people who are chimney sweeps where executed because they had a,
they had been cleaning chimneys and they had guns.
The equivalent,
they had charcoal on their,
on their cheeks.
They would,
people would,
they would rip off your shirt to see if you had a bruise from a recoiling rifle.
And they,
it wasn't just,
you know,
it wasn't a neutral massacre what it was.
They went areas of pair of Paris,
like Bellevue,
which is in the north east,
which had long been assumed to be a radical place and more Masa.
And that's where their collective memory of the forces of orders they liked to
call it,
uh,
was very,
very precise.
And that's where they went in and massacred them.
And that is,
uh,
the most chilling,
probably legacy,
uh,
of the,
of the whole thing.
Now I know it's easy to look at me and say,
God,
there's an old lefty.
You know,
why isn't the draw?
That's,
my wife says sometimes,
why don't you grow up,
but why don't you,
you know,
get over this.
You know,
I remember when I was a,
you know,
a student in Paris,
I remember going up to,
uh,
um,
there's a place that peerless has cemetery and there's the wall of the fit of,
hey,
it's called the wall of the federates.
And that's where they massacred lots of people and people used to go up there on
May Day and sometimes on the anniversary of the commune just to see where these
people fell with enormous more dignity than the people who,
who shot them.
And this was the ultimate lesson of the commune that would hang over Europe for
the left.
It was assigned that that the,
that the state is strong,
powerful and can be vicious.
Don't let anyone ever tell you that the victims of terrorism in any century are
any,
were proximately near the victims of state terrorism.
No matter how awful terrorism was in the anarchist attacks in the end of the
1890s at the beginning of the 1890s I'm going to talk to you about it cause I,
I'm interested in them.
But this was the real lesson of all of this as the state ever more stronger in
Europe since the consolidation of territorial monarchies in the,
in the 15th century,
the state growing in power with absolutism growing and power with the revolution
with Napoleon growing in power with the unification of national states,
the state could strike back with unparalleled savagery against those people who
got in a way.
And that's what happened at the commune in the Paris commune.
How many people died?
Minimum estimate,
15,000,
probably closer to 25,000.
Yet when they did the census of 1872 in Paris alone,
there were 10,000 less shoemakers than there had been before.
Shoemakers were an extraordinarily radical trade where they all hiding in their
aunt's house in early on.
Where were they?
You know,
th th the flames in golf,
the bodies,
they were gone and the amnesty for the Columbia.
Now the people in the commune,
uh,
wouldn't come til 1879 but it hung like a shadow over European politics and
French politics for years and years.
And you know there's a,
when you go up there,
when you,
if you go up to my mouth,
it's incredible because I was there once very,
very late in the afternoon.
And oddly enough,
I met this woman who went there every day and I said,
why you go there every day?
And she said she had some sort of lung disease and she couldn't get out of
Paris,
but she could go into perilous sheds.
And she knew where every tune was.
And she took us up to see the wall of the federation.
I was some with some friends when my mother long ago.
And I remember looking at that and just thinking,
I remember when I was a kid,
I read this book by Thomas Wolf called look,
homeward angel.
And in the end he says,
as he say,
said,
Oh,
lost.
And by the wind grieved ghost come back again.
That was the communist.
And we're going to go onto the state next time.
Have a good day.